so these two questions here it's
important that we wrap our minds around
how to manipulate these and not just
resort to the calculator because this is
just a warm-up for when you've got
algebra in here your calculator can
crunch these numbers when you hand it an
in fact we're learning and plus one
factorial or a 2n factorial it's just
going to spin the dummy out you can't
handle those so therefore you need to
get familiar with how to manipulate
these while you've got the numbers then
move on to the other each of these
questions it requires you to understand
factorization and canceling in a
particular way so have a look at this
top one clearly I could work this out by
doing a factorial whatever that happens
to be there do seven factorial whatever
that happens to be and then occular okay
but what I'm trying to do is like you
remember as you saw those numbers
increasing right eight factorial is a
lot more difficult ejaculate than seven
factorial be just because the numbers
start to get huge right so your brain is
try to avoid big numbers here's the way
I can do it it's money damage look what
yes it is okay just have a look at this
pair of lines here okay and we're very
good we trained this over the last few
weeks at factorizing identifying common
algebraic terms in this case five line
and then you pull them out the front and
you turned a difference into a point of
it do you see that this is something
times something not just something minus
something okay now the same way these
guys have lots of common factors for
instance because they've read factorials
what'll be a common factor and to be a
common factor and three and four five
and six and all the way up to seven you
see that so just like I pulled 5y out of
that binomial a minute I can pull seven
factorial
out of both of these terms okay once I
factorize it out what does that leave me
with
well there are eight lots of seven
factorial in here
I say hey how many lots of seven
factorial in here one so I subtract one
okay now you might not think seven times
seven factorial is a big improvement on
this but again remember what I'm trying
to do is avoid those big numbers and
it's marginally an improvement and it'll
be more of an improvement where this
becomes algebra later on and you have no
choice but to do this you can't just
chuck it into a customer same principle
applies here okay now I'm going to take
advantage of that unrolling thing I
showed you before because I noticed
there are lots of things here that can
cancel so I'm gonna write 8 times 7
times 6 times 5 that's the first half of
a factorial in the second half is just
this guy right why not stop it 4
factorial because that's something I can
cancel so on the bottom here I've got a
4 factorial I can kid so I'm just gonna
highlight that but then they have this
other four factorial also hanging around
I want to see if I kids or something
with that too so I'm gonna write it out
in longhand writing things out in
longhand is my way of identifying which
of the bits can I actually see in
commented then cancel have a look what
things stand out what kind of cancel
from the top and the bottom the 8
actually nicely fits exactly here you
see that's exactly 8 so if I cancel
before the two there this whole hand is
gone the 1 of course doesn't matter what
about this guy I can because pot all
money I told it to you pilot of this 3
part of this 6 rather these are three
okay so if that gets cancelled it will
become a a 2 so again what I'm left with
is that eights gone I've got a 7 times 2
times 5 done catch everything I think
everything else has been accounted for 7
times 10 is 70 okay now of course your
calculator you could have done that from
the beginning but let me emphasize again
you're trying to flex your muscles so
that when you get to algebra you can
manipulate all
is somewhat fluently okay